Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's endlich die Giotto Torte, die ich euch versprochen hab,
weil so, so, so viele von euch gesagt haben: "Kiki, mach doch mal eine richtig leckere Giotto Torte!
Vor allem eine, die nicht so schwer im Magen liegt!"
Und jetzt hab ich für euch das perfekte Rezept entwickelt.
Und ich habe hier schon die Zutaten für die leckere Haselnusscreme.
Dafür benötigen wir Schlagsahne(bitte ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank!), helle Haselnusscreme,
außerdem etwas Vanilleextrakt, Sahnefest, dann hab ich hier noch Mascarpone
und natürlich leckere Giotto Kügelchen. Und was wir auch noch benötigen
ist einmal mein Schkoladenbiskuit Boden.
Den hab ich hier - das ist auch nochmal ein kleiner Tipp für euch- den hab ich hier unter einem
feuchten, sauberen Geschirrtuch, damit der auch nicht austrocknet.
Schon durchgeschnitten, sodass wir 3 dünne Böden haben.
Und den Boden tränke ich gleich noch mit etwas Kaffee.
Und den Rest, den genieße ich dann einfach währen des Backens.
So, jetzt starten wir mit der Creme und die geht auch echt easy,
denn ich mag das ja immer ganz gerne, die Creme mit der Küchenmaschine aufzuschlagen,
indem ich alles rein gebe.
Wichtig ist halt nur die Reihenfolge.
Ich geb als erstes Mascarpone rein, dann Sahne damit es eben nicht so "aufplumpt"
und nicht die ganze Küche eingesaut ist, das ist der einfache Grund dafür.
Dann geb ich die Haselnusscreme dazu, Vanilleextrakt und dann wird das erstmal geschlagen.
Erst niedrig, dann immer ein bisschen höher und nach einer Minute kommt das Sahnefest dazu.
Nach insgesamt 3 ½min ist unsere Creme auch schon fertig und ich gebe hier jetzt
ungefähr 1/5 an die Seite. Das brauchen wir gleich noch zum Bestreichen der äußeren Torte.
Und für die schönen Tupfer, die wir obendrauf geben. Könnt ihr auch solange gerne
in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Und zur restlichen Creme gebe ich jetzt kleingehackte oder klein geviertelte Giottos rein.
Und ihr habt vielleicht schon gemerkt: ich hab hier eigentlich kein Süßungsmittel drin.
Also hier die Giottos, die sind ja auch schon süß, die Haselnusscreme ist süß und mehr braucht
ihr auch gar nicht.
Und ihr kennt's schon von mir: mein Konstrukt. Ich hab ja immer, wenn ich Torten befülle
oder generell wenn ich Torten mache, immer ein ganz bestimmtes Konstrukt.
Ich habe ganz unten eine drehbare Tortenplatte. Die hilft euch enorm,
es geht dann alles super easy von der Hand.
Da drüber die Tortenplatte, die ihr am liebsten mögt für die Torte.
Meistens sollte das dann auch farblich passen, ich nehm jetzt hier zum Beispiel rot.
Und danach brauchen wir einen Tortenring.
Ich gebe zuallererst den ersten Boden ganz unten rein, tränke den mit Kaffee,
ihr könnt auch wenn zum Beispiel Kinder mitessen oder ihr einfach keinen Kaffee mögt,
dann könntet ihr auch Kakao nehmen oder was auch lecker ist:
Milch mit Haselnuss Sirup. Stell ich mir auch sehr lecker vor.
Und dann geben wir auch schon die Hälfte der Creme dazu.
So, die Torte ist geschichtet und jetzt geb ich hier einfach ein Cakeboard
oben drauf, damit sie eben nicht austrocknet.
Ihr könnt da auch gerne ein Tuch nehmen wenn ihr mögt.
Und dann muss die ganze Torte jetzt nochmal 2h gekühlt werden, dann wird die Creme
auch richtig schön fest. Ihr könnt den Tortenring entfernen und danach
zeig ich euch die Deko! Bis gleich!
So, die Wartezeit ist rum und jetzt können wir die Torte dekorieren.
Das Tolle ist wir haben hier jetzt noch die Creme von eben,
also wir müssen jetzt keine neue Creme aufschlagen.
Jetzt werd ich erstmal die Torte rundherum ganz dünn damit einstreichen.
Dann nehm ich mir Mandelkrokant für die Seiten und natürlich ein paar Giottos für obendrauf.
Ich persönlich liebe Mandelkrokant, deswegen hab ich heute den genommen.
Ihr könntet jetzt aber auch zum Beispiel Haselnusskrokant nehmen oder sogar
gehackte und geröstete Haselnüsse für den Rand der Torte eben.
Und dann hab ich mir heute mal meine Blumentülle genommen und mal so ein
ganz anderes fancy Muster gemacht auf die Torte. Also nicht dieses klassische,
diese klassischen Tupfer, die man so kennt.
Das war jetzt gerade so ein Einfall.
Also macht's gerne genauso nach, denn ich finde sie sieht total beeindruckend aus.
Und im Anschluss seht ihr natürlich auch noch den Anschnitt
und dann lassen wir uns die schmecken, nacher kommen noch meine Eltern
also passt das eigentlich wunderbar, dass wir die leckere Giotto Torte heute gemacht haben.
Euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken.
Schreibt mir unbedingt in die Kommentare, welches Rezept ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet.
Habt ihr eine besondere Süßigkeit, die ihr immer essen könnt?
Und soll ich daraus eine Torte zaubern?
Dann schreibt's mir auf jeden Fall hier rein.
Ansonsten findet ihr die genauen Mengenangaben in der Videobeschreibung
und natürlich dürft ihr das Abo nicht vergessen, denn dann bekommt ihr
auch mit, wenn's wieder so leckere Torten auf meinem Kanal gibt.
Hast du auch noch was zu sagen?
(H: Ich will einfach, dass du aufhörst zu reden, damit ich essen kann.)
Okay, ich muss aufhören zu reden.
Euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen.
Tschüss!